-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night"
and it's Monday.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden today
welcomed players
from the 2020 WNBA champions
Seattle Storm
to the White House,
but, unfortunately,
they didn't have any ideas
about Afghanistan.
[ As Biden ]
Well, thought I'd ask.
Thanks for coming in.
[ Laughter ]
The Pentagon announced yesterday
that it has asked U.S. airlines
to help with Afghanistan
evacuation efforts.
Okay, but remember --
they can barely evacuate people
from LaGuardia.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Congressman
Matt Gaetz
married his girlfriend
over the weekend.
Apparently, it was the only way
she'd let him have
a bachelor party.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump was booed
by his own supporters
at a rally on Saturday
after he encouraged them
to receive
the coronavirus vaccine.
They came out to see you
because they love you
and they ended up booing you.
Man, you really are from Queens.
[ Laughter ]
It's a tense --
It's a tense time in the studio.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Former President Trump
on Saturday
criticized
President Biden's handling
of the situation in Afghanistan
and said,
"Vietnam looks like
a master class in strategy,
compared
to Joe Biden's catastrophe."
But take that
with a grain of salt
because Trump never went
to Vietnam
or class.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
President Biden's approval
rating has fallen below 50%
for the first time
in his presidency
and, if his approval numbers
fall any lower,
he could start to hit
Trump's all-time highs.
[ Laughter ]
Today is the last day
of New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo's administration.
Well, I'd say keep in touch,
but that's kinda
what got you in trouble,
in the first place.
[ Laughter ]
New York City on Saturday
held its
We Love NYC Homecoming Concert
in Central Park
and, to guarantee
that the concert
didn't become a superspreader,
they held it in a hurricane.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
billionaire Elon Musk
announced last week
that his company is releasing
a so-called Tesla Bot designed
to do unsafe, repetitive,
or boring tasks.
Basically, it was designed
to hang out with Elon Musk.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.